the catholics should be the holdout here
because the catholics
just never really went along with all
that kind of modern individualism
liberalism they just kind of rejected
that they're pretty pretty old school
about these things and yet i saw this
article the other day a postmodern
catholic divinity student let's go for a
moment of grace and this this student
was describing how he he wanted to visit
a hindu temple so he wanted to go visit
a hindu temple ceremony for an
assignment
in his uh graduate seminar
and so
he he didn't end up doing that because
he was afraid of coronavirus so he just
did it online which makes the story even
funnier but he's there and he's sort of
digitally participating in this
and then he's watching it and kind of
taking notes but he said no i shouldn't
just watch it i should participate in
this as well i'm doing this wrong i'm
observing
but i'm not part of the puja i'm not i'm
not distancing myself so he paused the
video takes a deep breath exhales then
he stares into ganesha's eyes and
something wonderful happens i'm
entranced mesmerized ganesha's eyes seem
to stare back as the chanting wafts over
me i slide into its rhythm one voice
just breathing just being the chanting
the distance of bells as the puja ends
i'm still staring into ganesha's eyes
the eyes of ganesha are all that exists
all that there is in my world
what happened a moment of grace
even even though i was in a
non-christian setting
i i must find a deeper answer that goes
beyond imposing christian theology and
values on a hindu puja
in other words
he's
worshiping pagan idols
to own
the
traditionalists to own the conservatives
to own the people who don't believe you
should emancipate yourself from
everything
you you actually hear this argument
sometimes you'll hear people say look
i'm going to violate some
well-established tenet of christianity
whether it's on
i don't know theology of the body you
know sex issues or whether it's on
liturgical issues or whether it's on
you know christological issues or
whatever i'm going to violate some some
important doctrine of christianity
because that's really the most christian
thing i could do
the most christian thing i could do
would be to worship pagan idols because
it's so open-minded it's not
it's not and there's nothing there's
nothing new about this that people think
this is some new revelation no
worshipping pagan idols is the default
for humanity okay that's what everyone
did for all of human history everywhere
until
ancient israelites
and then until
that idea of worshiping one god finds
its culmination it's fulfillment in
christianity
and now we're going back to that
people want your data they want your
information and a lot of the time they
don't want to do very good stuff with
that information they will try to take
your identity payment apps like venmo
cash app and others make payments really
easy but then if you don't pay attention
to your privacy settings
some of them will share your personal
information a recent report found that
payment apps share user data with third
parties such as banks fraud monitoring
services some even share it with
marketing firms it's important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are
affecting our lives every single day we
put our information at risk on the
internet in an instant a cyber criminal
could harm what's yours your finances
your credit your good reputation good
thing there is lifelock which detects a
wide range of identity theft
for instance your social security number
for sale on the dark web you have access
to a dedicated restoration specialist if
you are a victim no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can keep what's yours with lifelock by
norton right now join save up to 25 off
your first year at lifelock.com slash
knowles that is lifelock.com
knowles for 25 off
there is nothing new under the sun folks
i assure you
the worship of pagan idols
is is not new
this actually there was an another
article good article on unheard how
satanism conquered america just
observing that satanism is just
untrammeled individualism do whatever
you want ye shall be his gods that's
what the serpent says to eve in the
garden of eden that's how john milton
kind of views satanism too and so when
we just do whatever we want at any given
time that there is really no distinction
here and that's why these sorts of
things have uh darker
symbols associated with them there's
nothing new under the sun we look at our
new government oh we have the
enlightenment
brilliant genius scientific
rule of the experts no it's just
oligarchy it's there have been a lot of
oligarchies in history and we're
descending into one now as well
and you know i i mentioned angelo
codavilla earlier we've just lost one of
the great the one of the great minds on
this issue so uh let's not forget about
it let's not memory hold that let's
recognize let's see this moment clearly
for what it is let's not get lost in
ganesha's eyes or whatever let's not get
lost in dr fauci's eyes either let's see
this for what it is let's decide what
kind of society we want to live and what
government we want to live under and
let's exercise our political authority
such as we still have it to do so i'm so
glad you like that clip i like that clip
too i thought it was pretty good
if you would like more of that kind of
content head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play subscribe
to the michael knowles show
t h e space m i c h a e l space k w l e
s space s h o w
t h a n k s
s e e y o u n e x t
t i m e
[Music]
[Music]